mesdames messieurs bonsoir peut-être
allez-vous nous jugé futile mais ce que
nous avons retenu d'abord des événements
de la journée c'est la publication de
cet album
cet album cartonné trois ans et demi
après la mort d'hergé
voici la dernière des aventures de
tintin elle ne ressemble pas du tout aux
23 précédents car c'est un album
inachevé un album dessiné au crayon ça
lui donne un peu l'aspect émouvant d'un
testament olographe on pénètre avec ce
document dans l'atelier dans les secrets
de fabrication de ce grand dessinateur
hergé dont on découvre chaque jour
en le relisant qu'il était peut-être
aussi après tout et peut être d'abord un
journaliste et un journaliste de très
grand talent et me diras foule même
esquissé même raturé il ya dans cet
album tout ce qu'il faut pour une
nouvelle histoire de tintin les
personnages tintin bien sûr milou la
castafiore haddock et des petits
nouveaux
l'intrigué cette fois ci on est plongé
dans le monde de l'art avec ses faux ses
trafics ses experts le suspense quelques
meurtres de l'exotisme et la trame est
hissé pour que tente un reprennent
l'enquète l'album publié ces jours-ci
est un ouvrage inachevé tout le travail
de création
c'est moi qui le fais avait déclaré et
rejet il ya quelques années
paris avait très bien exprimé sa volonté
d'après nissan continue et plus et même
s'il ne l'avait pas digestive mois
qu'une oeuvre d'art
appartient uniquement à son auteur est
quelque chose de tout à fait individuel
et voilà c'était pas pensable que
quelqu'un d'autre
face à lui même même avec talent avec
tout ce congrès serait smart plus été le
tintin d'hergé hergé avait donc demandé
que tintin s'achève avec la propre mort
ces derniers albums se termine à la page
sans le mot fin